der deutsche bundestag hat heute noch
einmal über gleichberechtigung
diskutiert kann man nicht oft genug
waren drei tage vor dem equal pay day
der ist nämlich am montag auch nach
bereinigten berechnungen verdienen
frauen bei uns immer noch 6 prozent
weniger wohlgemerkt für die gleiche
tätigkeit
das heißt in manchen berufen heißt es
nach wie vor kein gen ist kein geld also
bzw weniger geld das geht alles sehr
langsam voran das frauenwahlrecht zum
beispiel haben wir erst seit 100 jahren
fand auch später nicht jeder gut ich bin
dafür dass die frau liegt wählen dürfen
warum nicht eine frau gehört am kochtopf
schön wir noch mal zurückkommen ach
warum nicht
das hätte mehr gefragt auch unser
aktueller bundestag in berlin taugt
leider nicht mehr zum vorbild was den
frauenanteil angeht steht er auf einer
stufe mit dem sudan es leider kein witz
so kann es nicht weitergehen findet
friedemann weise ratschläge in die
fresse mit friedemann weise
es ist beschämend der frauenanteil im
bundestag ist so niedrig wie lange nicht
31,3 prozent wenn es nach ak ginge
hätten die nicht meine eigene toilette
in manchen köpfen hat sich ja leider
seit den 50er jahren kaum was verändert
sind sie für gleichberechtigung
immerhin hat er eine sekunde überlegt
aber ist doch traurig nur 31,3 prozent
frauen und die zahl hat mir ein mann
gesagt das heißt in wirklichkeit sind
wohl eher 12 ich persönlich setze voll
auf die nächste generation man die denkt
da zum glück ganz anders es ist richtig
dass wir alle auch noch besser darin
werden müssen wie wir auch frauen
beteiligen und frauen sind eben auch im
parlament eine wichtige unterstützung
auch für uns in der fraktion
unterstützung auch für uns in der
fraktion
genau so eine fraktionssitzung kann
lange dauern da können so ein paar
unterstützende häppchen zwischendurch
nicht sagen aber immerhin verdienen
männliche und weibliche abgeordnete
gleich viel
natürlich nur wenn man die
nebeneinkünfte weglässt denn da sind
unter den 25 top verdienern gerade mal
drei frauen
dabei kämpfen die schon solang für eine
gerechte bezahlung
[Musik]
ja und 14 jahre später verdienen sie
immer noch weniger als peter so hat man
heute ein schickes worte für gender pay
gap viele männer finden den
gehaltsunterschied richtig die sagen wir
brauchen auch mehr geld wir fahren ja
schließlich die teureren autos aber aber
das ja quatsch frauen fahren ja oft
dieselben autos wenn der mann getrunken
hat wir brauchen endlich
geschlechtergerechtigkeit und zwar bis
in die führungsetagen hätten den abgas
betrug bei vw frauen zu verantworten
gehabt wir hätten die reagiert es tut
uns leid und jetzt entschädigen wir die
betrogenen schöne vorstellung aber die
selten doch jetzt in wolfsburg in der
geschlossenen darum mein ratschlag die
zukunft muss weiblich sein und es gibt
hoffnung hier kreta thunberg ein vorbild
für eine generation stellen sie sich vor
das wäre ein junge
da würden noch alle fragen wieso heißt
der kreta mitglied gewachsen
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort